I'm so glad that some of our
conversations are on meditation so I
have a number of questions that are I
get on meditation uh what time there are
just many many many types of meditation
and I suppose they're probably almost
all good I've only experienced
Transcendental Meditation but there's uh
the type of meditation that I do is a
mantra Transcendental Meditation I think
there are a number of them that have
mantras and the way it works is there's
a sound that you repeat in your mind
that takes your thoughts away from your
thoughts and puts them into that sound
for example oh might be an example and
you repeat and you sit there quietly and
you repeat
um to yourself mentally takes your
thoughts away from all the other stuff
and then eventually that disappears and
you go into a subconscious state and
that's a state of peacefulness and in
that subconscious state there's
creativity and there are a lot of
different thoughts subconscious State
really controls you more than your
conscious state so that's what the
experience is like but I think if you
experiment with different types of
meditation it's all good and there are
many apps and many ways of doing that so
I really encourage you I know for me
Transcendental Meditation has I would
attribute it to giving me more success
than any other thing that I've had in my
life because it gave me the Equanimity
that centeredness the calmness to deal
with all the things that came at me and
it also gave me the creativity that
bubbles up from the subconscious so
that's what meditation is to me